the discipline that I learned from sport
really helped the creativity because if
you still give yourself some sense of
structure then you're working towards
something and that's the same in sport
if you really want to get to the top you
have to be creative how you're going to
push your mind and your body to truly
achieve greatness it's all about mindset
we're brought to you today by Roca
unlock 20 off your order with the code
richroll roca.com
[Music]
I can't believe I have you here I'm so
excited to talk to you you're like this
Unicorn it's insane the more I learn
about your story and I was thinking
about in the history of Hollywood has
there ever been a world champion athlete
who's also been nominated for an Oscar
do you know what I did Google that at
some point you did you know
it yeah and I think I found someone like
way way back and but I think it was more
on the acting side I think Kobe Bryant
though yeah Kobe well you know there was
Johnny Weissmuller there's people like
that but also they went into Hollywood
when their career was over right in
sports right like you're still doing it
like you're doing these you're on these
parallel tracks and you know achieving
Great Heights in both simultaneously
which is just bananas yeah I'm pretty
crazy and my husband can attest to that
so uh man I was I was born kicking and
screaming and running out running out of
the womb so
just always had such a huge desire in my
belly it's like this fire in my belly to
do things
to um
just so much drive to achieve to push to
excel
and I do not know where that comes from
I don't know if it's the calvinistic
love of suffering or what the hell it is
that it was that the way that you were
brought up I know your dad was somebody
who kind of you know provided a lot of
of support and structure to help you
achieve your goals and your mom was more
on the artistic side so that makes sense
but was there an expectation or a
pressure or is that something that's
self-generated it's self-generated but
then when you consider that I'm the
youngest of four in a Scottish family
um where it's pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and just keep going uh no
morning no whining fight for your food
at the table
but a lot of love and support so it's
it's both of those elements I think that
have bred this drive and have kind of
filtered this drive in me yeah
the sporting side of you
is not a case in which you discovered
Triathlon later in life and pursued it
sport is bred into you from the get-go
beginning with rugby of all things so
can you tell that story of falling in
love with rugby as a young girl yeah you
know I loved to get dirty I still do and
I went to watch my brother play rugby so
I remember holding my dad's hand and
going down to the rugby fields in
Scotland you know the rain's coming at
you sideways and I said Dad Dad I want
to go with that and he's like well Liz
you do know there's no girls playing
right and I'm like great I'll get to be
up on the boys so
um yeah he just kind of threw me in
there and it was a rough and tumble of
it I absolutely loved that and I love
the team nature of it uh and I think I
you know if anyone told me I couldn't do
anything that was it redirect taboo you
know that kind of sentiment I have a
sense that's still the case yeah pretty
much what has to be if you're in
Hollywood because everyone's going to
show you can't well it's just a yeah
it's a it's a you know of all Industries
it's the one where you're exposed to
failure probably yep most regularly oh
yeah minute by minute yeah and your
story is certainly full of a lot of
noise yes but on the rugby thing I mean
you you're downplaying a little bit I
mean you were the only girl of like 250
players right and you guys ended up like
winning the Scottish championships when
you were 10. yep so you were like what
was that like mixing it up in the scrum
as a 10 year old girl it was it was
really funny because a lot of the boys
initially would not want to touch me or
they you know I'd walk on the perch
right and they would laugh and they
would Giggle and they would point
fingers so you had to get a really thick
skin but then as I sort of grew into the
team right and and and they recognized
that I was good at what I did
they all got behind me and then you just
become this unit and that's what I loved
and then I became the captain of the
team
and yeah it was just like it was the
most amazing experience because it was
filled with such adversity like I
remember going to rugby on a Saturday
morning it'd be freezing cold you
weren't allowed to wear gloves you'd be
in shorts in the winter with snow and I
didn't have a changing room right I'm
the only girl so all the boys have these
nice hot showers I just had this little
cubicle it was a woman's toilet and a
you know crappy Rugby Club in Scotland
and I remember like not being able to
get my laces and done because we're so
cold and I'd be washing myself I was
only like seven or eight I could wash
myself off in the Basin and you know all
this kind of stuff so I think that
adversity really helped me uh to then
achieve the things that I have in later
life and my parents it's like they were
always there they were always supportive
but it was a case of we're gonna drop
you off and you go figure it out but
we'll be there to pick you off at the
end
so and yeah I think that's a testament
to their parenting that sense of yours
in order to be there for you but at the
same time they're sending you off to
figure out you know skin your knees
without them you know putting a net down
oh totally you needed they didn't come
to every match it's not like you know so
many of my friends and their parents
here every single game they go to and da
da da it's like hell's no you know they
would come to the back one that's great
but the rest of the time it was and we
even went on bus trips I remember we did
a tour around the country and I must
have only been nine or ten and it was
just all man and me yeah
I'm like flashing on the opening scene
and the biopic of your life you know you
know getting knocked down and scrubbing
the Dirt Off Your yeah but I used to do
the best thing ever I remember coming
home and I'd be getting in the hot bath
um and I had a love to count how many
bruises and how many scratches I had my
it was like a badge of honor you know
I'd be like oh yeah you know I was 12
today and
um and the best bit about it is my niece
Zoe who's 12 now she plays rugby and
she's amazing in Scotland yep in
Scotland and then so I go to watch her
every time I go home and she's the same
she loves all the mud and the bruises
and the bashes and it's she's like a
mini me which is quite funny but then
you would go and do ballet in the
afternoon right or like afterwards or
yep yep in the afternoon so it's this
like I'm getting this sense or this
picture of the yin and yang you know
like there's always these tensions in
this case the masculine and The Feminine
but the creative and the athletic or the
kind of
um need that you have to have as an
athlete to have that that motor that
self-will or that ability to push
yourself to be disciplined and to suffer
but then on the creative side to know
when
um to be in presence to be in the
allowing like you can't force a creative
result like you can force a strength
result or an athletic result it's a
different equation that you have to
solve for no it totally is and I think
that I didn't I didn't realize that
right growing up that one was helping
the other
and I was always told along the way if
you want to be good at anything you have
to choose one thing and gorgeous yeah
that was like right in my outline like
my whole life like there's athletes and
there's artists right and never the
twain shall meet these are people who
are configured differently yep and you
it's up to you to figure out which one
of those two if you're interested in
both you kind of have to pick one
totally no nobody's gonna tell you that
it's cool to do both no absolutely and
and you're kind of like an outlier in
both right so you know as an athlete
you're you're you know everyone makes
one of the artists and they have a
completely different time clock they
stay up all night smoke they don't take
care of their bodies they have they
cannot understand the athletes
um and then equally you know
um the the the the the artist is like
you know they have no sense of the
athlete what that's like you know
neither Camp can truly understand and
yet I feel like there's so much
similarity and there's so much you can
draw down from from each from each craft
so what would be some of those things so
I think the main thing is the discipline
that I learned from sport
uh really helped the creativity because
as ethereal is
being creative and when is that good
idea going to come if you still give
yourself some sense of structure then
you're working towards something and
it's certainly when it comes to to
screenplay writing right there's a lot
of structure it's almost like
if you know the structure enough then
you can let it go and it becomes
intuitive and that's the same in sport
if you train enough
to push yourself to the limits enough
then in the race you'll find your Zone
so it's kind of like the same
um and then equally I think in sport if
you really want to get to the top you
have to be creative you have to think
outside the box about how you're going
to push your mind and your body to truly
achieve greatness and you know I went
down a lot of systems and sports you
know a lot of national bodies the
British national body and certainly this
was back kind of in the 90s and the
early 2000s when they weren't as
developed as they are now
but it was so it was like okay there's
one way to do this
and if you're not good at this one way
then you're never going to be a world
champion and I wasn't good at that one
way and I'm like well yeah but I still
think I could be good
um so the creativity allowed me to
investigate so many other ways and I
love it because my husband Simon says
it's it's you know a cargo net it's not
a ladder um to the top explain that it's
a cargo net cargo net means there's many
different ways to swap a ladder there's
one one yeah yeah yes
um yeah and that's that's kind of a
beautiful analogy because that's how I
think I've gotten to the top in both
it's just kind of like really going to
the side and up and down and up and to
the side and across and and being at
peace with that
um as well which has taken time right
because you are an outlier and you are
bucking the system and as a result there
will be pushback or resistance or
criticism for trying to find a different
way oh yeah yeah all the time yeah and I
I think it it it it puts the lie to the
test this notion that the artist is
struck with inspiration after you know a
pack of cigarettes and a bottle of you
know bourbon at 3am and and and you know
helps one to realize and this is a very
kind of Steven pressfield
um Seth go kind of thing that that
creativity is a discipline in the same
way the pursuit of excellence in support
is it requires rigor and structure
accountability and all of those things
you have to create those structures in
order to make space for the creativity
to appear exactly in that idea of like
you know the war or the war of art or
turning pro like are you a professional
like if you're a professional creative
then you show up for it every day in the
same way you show up for practice for
your sport you can't say I have writer's
block is that would be like saying you
know I I have I have sport block today
like I'm not going you know I'm not
going to show up for practice but
equally it's like even if you do have
some kind of block or you're not making
the forward momentum that you want to
it's saying how can I get a positive
result today what does that mean what
does that look like and having again
that's that cargo net analogy where you
know what you deem to be successful on
any given day
you know is is different for every
individual but certainly for me in sport
right I would have many shitty days I
mean any top athlete I'll tell you that
many many shitty days I've dealt with
Lyme disease chronic injuries so how can
you find something positive that you can
still make a step forward in some
capacity whether that's mentally or
physically
and similarly you know on the on the art
front on storytelling front on script
writing front you know it's
understanding how your brain works what
suits you what doesn't how to still find
kind some kind of momentum even when
you're having a bad day
um and maybe that's I'm I
I'm such a positive person I love to
find the positivity in anything and I
don't know if that's because I grew up
you know my dad's pretty pretty tough
Scottish man you know nothing is ever
going to impress him however it has now
I'm getting the truth this is what I was
getting at earlier yeah but you know
nothing really impresses them right you
know and that real Scottish you know
bring people down that were successful
um you know whereas my mom is the
opposite right gushing and everything's
amazing and and so it's like you you
kind of strike the balance between both
uh but they create your driving force to
understand how to find positivity in any
situation
so the rigor of sport applied to
creativity enhances creativity and the
creativity in turn
enhances your uh capability to perform
as an athlete by putting you in a in a
space of curiosity right to not just do
what the coach says or follow the plan
right to shoulder responsibility and
always be searching for new and
different ways of of you know finding
that extra Notch of performance and I
think to your point it's self-reflection
and a lot of athletes still
follow the coach they'll follow the
system
and they won't take the responsibility
and they won't self-reflect who am I
you know what am I good at what am I not
good at where are my weaknesses what am
I you know when we talk about characters
we talk about the Heart of Darkness
What's Your Heart of Darkness you know I
can tell you right now what mine is it's
that I'm not special
it's that I don't stand out that's my
Heart of Darkness so every Behavior
lends itself to the pursuit of never
having to face that Heart of Darkness
so when we're writing a screenplay are
characters that's what it's about
finding that Heart of Darkness and that
drives your story that drives your
character
um so having that kind of level of
self-reflection and then of course my
husband being a psychologist and
understanding the science behind it has
really helped me say if that's the case
let's look at my training and literally
figure out where am I stressing myself
physically and emotionally in any given
day in any given week when I look at
performance of something I look at the
performance mentally and physically and
then how do I be creative in finding
ways to progress and again that's that
creativity helping and then you create a
structure out of that and then you
analyze with your kind of science brain
and that helps you sort of achieve right
yeah right right right right right an
example that would spring to mind in the
triathlon context would be uh you're
feeling that day and you're having
a terrible run or ride or something like
that and instead of flogging yourself
for it or giving up or stopping instead
to say well let's just work on technique
like how can I like focus on the stride
or whatever how can I perfect these
little things that often get overlooked
when you're doing Tempo work or pushing
yourself harder and you're just trying
to generate Watts or a certain heart
rate right and then I might even spam
that out and say okay that's kind of a
physical process go well let's look at a
mental One how can I make myself feel
really good today because I'm having a
shitty day you know is it my training
body you know that's been so critical to
me across the years or training partners
and Heidi
um affects me influenced me how I bond
with them that's a huge part of the
social piece of it the joy I find in it
because when you're suffering with
someone else you open up your soul to
them and so you have a very unique Bond
so having the right training Partners
depending on how you're feeling and
where do I train I'm very impacted by
the environment you know
um doesn't need to be in a you know a
beautiful climb that always has brought
about good memories I've had good
performances on before so I can go there
and say this hill means something to me
it's gonna it's gonna really make me
feel good and then I'm gonna you know
work on the technical piece and so again
that's just finding sort of positive
elements that you can utilize all the
time so you come away from every session
with something that has moved you
forward in some way yeah I think that
taking responsibility piece comes with
experience right when you're new you do
have to you know allow somebody else to
guide you in a more comprehensive way
than you need later because you don't
know anything right
um but then it's about slowly becoming
more from an intuitive place right as
you start to learn about yourself and I
suppose in the screenwriting context
like the converse of that would be the
person who you know doesn't know the
rules but thinks they do but is intent
on you know being the lone genius in
writing the radical screenplay
and then refusing to take Studio notes
or whatever you know the development
executive tells you this doesn't work
and you not being able to hear that and
saying you don't understand what a
genius I am right right and I mean I'm
super Lucky in that I've made an amazing
man who has spent his life being a top
researcher so I think you know digging
deep into the landscape of any craft
that you're in and finding absolute joy
in the Mastery of The Craft and what
does that mean so taking every you know
screenwriting class we can imagine
knowing every Theory that's out there
kind of almost like knowing everything
so you can let it go and find your own
way which again is ever evolving and it
depends on which project you're working
with which artists you're collaborating
with you know is it a studio film is it
an independent film there's so many
different facets but that's kind of the
beauty in it
um so yeah just kind of I think and it's
the same sport knowing almost you know
getting obsessive about knowing
everything so that then you can find
your own little path right well
triathletes are notorious for just being
obsessed with data and they walk around
with blinders on and just think about
their training and it's so
individualistic right it's about you and
you right screenwriting filmmaking is a
collaborative art right it's political
there's a lot of strong personalities a
lot of opinions there's money involved
there's so many complexities that puzzle
is comprised of millions of pieces right
and it's you know very challenging for
the most savvy political operator and
the most talented creative to navigate
that to a place where a movie actually
gets made it's like a miracle any movie
right right and that's an incredibly
different skill set right than just you
know I need to hit these watts and I'm
training seven hours a day just it's
just me in the basement or you know me
out on the pavement it isn't it's not
right because you're always having to
navigate the many different things
that's going to make you have a good
performance on any given day whether
that's you know how you're gonna sleep
what you're gonna eat uh what the
facility is like then you've got you
know as you are doing that activity all
of the tiny little details that come
into making that a good session so for
example swimming you know technique
in summer are you kidding me it's like
okay if you've got a slight pivot of the
right hand and then you're coming and
then you know get that elbow high and da
da da da you're thinking about all the
muscles so there's so many different
things that come together to create a
good performance
um that you have to think about on a
daily basis so I think actually I've
developed and you're not good at it
until you're not thinking about it at
all right which is what we all seek and
it comes
very rarely you know of course we all
know it's called being in the zone right
and
I've experienced it only a handful of
times to a real top level
um and that is the thing that everybody
is chasing when it all comes together
and you barely remember it but there's
just this beautiful meditative moment
where your mind and body have just gone
and it's poetry yeah yeah
there's only so much you can do to
invite that into your life it has its
own energy you can set up the
circumstances for that to arrive but you
can never put yourself in a position to
be dependent on that right and I think
that through hours you know I was always
known as an athlete that would train a
lot I try and put myself in every single
circumstance I could
in order to um create those neural
Pathways right so that I could cope with
anything and still come up with the
goods
and I think that that's again why I've
reached success is I've just kind of
worked harder than anyone else you know
I've pushed to the absolute
limit day upon day upon day and taking
great joy in that as well like what am I
capable of today
and and and I really think about like
why where does this need come from and
again you know coming back to my dad and
it's interesting a lot of our scripts
have father-daughter relationships in it
I love my Dad I'm so close with him
um but you know he is from that school
of if you're too emotional you're weak
and my mom was a very emotional person
so from a very young age I saw his
emotions being a weakness
so I thought if I could wrestle my brain
and get on top of it that I was a winner
that I'd succeeded so I think my pursuit
of finding that Zen in sport that that
zone that moment is all about have I
been able to control my brain
um
oof it's getting deep and dark in here
well and your emotions when they
um
should and need to come out when being a
motive is is a benefit right you know
when you're writing you need to be in
touch with that sensibility and when
your dad comes in and you find that it's
helpful for you to kind of shut it down
a little bit to grit yourself through
whatever painful experience you're about
to encounter right interestingly I wrote
my Master's thesis on something called
task emotion Theory don't ask me too
much about it because I can't even
bloody remember but the essence of it is
taking the emotional essence or the
value of an emotion and putting that in
a character
um when you're when you're acting so
even if that emotional you know quality
is nerves or anxiety you're seeing that
as kind of having a value
and then you're taking that and you're
putting it in to fuel you it's almost
like you're you're gas right
um so I kind of saw
emotion as a good thing rather than a
bad thing so you take that emotion and
you fuel it towards
you you use it as a task emotion
interesting so yeah that's what happens
in theater School you write thesis
papers I thought it was just mask work
and you know I know dancing
no but you know the funny thing is is I
you know I studied my undergraduate in
drama and English uh in in at
Loughborough university in England and
it was a very very theoretical degree
and I loved it I loved just digging deep
into the theory of theater and the
history and you know all of that
um and again that critical analysis has
really helped me now that I'm in the
world of Storytelling and screenplay
writing and it it's far you know the
magic is that you don't see it as an
audience member but the brutality is is
every single tiny little piece is an
intricate bit that is put together to
create this end result and it's the same
in sport you train for hours and hours
and hours and hours to have this perfect
performance and then everyone goes oh my
God you're so amazing you're so lucky
wow you're so talented and I'm thinking
no idea what I mean and I've had
I've had arguments with age group first
I'm not joking like if I'm super like
maybe I'm hungry or I'm tired I remember
one one day being in the shower after a
master's swim session and this lady said
to me oh man I would love to just be
able to train all day and I said would
you like to pay your mortgage by
training all day do you know I mean
there's just no again it's an amazing
thing I love it and I feel so privileged
and lucky to have done it but at the
same time it's hard work yeah
yeah yeah I'm sure you get asked all the
time how these two worlds inform each
other how being an athlete makes you a
better screenwriter vice versa but I'm
sure these worlds come into conflict
also and work across purposes with each
other when you're on a deadline and you
really want to get out and ride or you
feel like what wins when those Two
Worlds Collide in that way
um at the moment I think because my life
has been so much about training that
that you know
I'll just like not sleep and get up and
get my three hours of treatment like
you'll get up at two in the morning
three in the morning like if it's a busy
day no matter what yeah and I'm sitting
here thinking
you just went to the Oscars you're
having this incredible moment right now
where doors are opening up and you're
probably getting offered all kinds of
cool stuff to do I know you just got
back from London and did this fashion
thing and you earned that and it's okay
to go do that like you've trained a lot
like you've got to take a break it's
cool it's always there so it's it's like
you know this this this moment will not
visit you again and I'm sure you'll go
on and have many more successes but
there's only one first and there's
something really special about that and
it would be tragic from my perspective
if you like shunned those because you
needed to be on your trainer oh totally
yeah totally and I think like I I to be
honest I wrestle with that a lot because
I think
to get to the level I have in sport it's
an addiction
it's it's not like I'm saying to you I'm
just gonna go train because I I want to
do well at a race or I want to be fit no
it's an addiction yeah like like to put
a exclamation point on this I mean you
you so the film premiered at the Toronto
Film Festival yep 2020 fall of 20 20.
yeah right is that right and you like
left the screen and like drove five
hours to go compete in the world
championship
haha but you know what I like that crazy
you know it's also part of who I am
and that's where my joy comes from so I
think it's like finding and I hate the
word balance but just assessing every
every day like
where's the importance and can I face
you know this need to train
and push out aside and focus on what's
important and I think that the balance
will start to turn as we get more films
going and because really truly the only
thing that takes me away from training
in a way is the joy of the creativity
when we're collaborating when we're on
set when I'm working through a problem
and then I'm just in this
place of wonderment about the world so
if I can kind of push aside those the
obsessive the obsessiveness that you
apply to sport is just transferred over
to the joy and the love of solving a
creative problem totally oh it is but at
least I feel like
that is more
um
enhancing in my life because any story
that we're doing any project that we're
a part of it has some bigger purpose I
want the films and stories I tell and
it's forever yeah yeah you lay it down
and it's for other people to see and to
have an impact on and those are the
types of projects that we're choosing to
do you know um
um balance
you said when you have all these
projects going on then maybe you'll have
more balance and yeah
first of all no you won't but secondly
that's still
presumes that you're in pursuit of
balance and I don't think that you are I
think you're somebody who has come to
terms with yourself that balances not
for you or you feel alive in your
YouTube extreme approach to your life
which is something I share and
appreciate it and then you know and it
took me a long time to not feel guilty
about that right and to let go of trying
to adhere to some imaginary social
standard of what a balanced life should
be and and look like and you're an
example of that and somebody who I know
has thought a lot about that word
balance and what it means oh yeah and
and I hate it and I love it all at the
same time I think it means different
things to different people I think for
me it means sitting back
and understanding maybe what's important
or how to fuel your soul in a different
way and not going down the rabbit Hall
of obsession to the point of it breaking
you down which it has done in the past
and it can continue to do sometimes
um you know I kind of dig I push push
push and then I fall off a cliff and
that seems to be my rhythm in life right
right but the I think the trick or the
Jedi move is to
is to not fall off the cliff like to
push and know yourself well enough
because you know it's not a marathon
it's an ultra marathon right and you got
a lot going on and a big bright future
ahead and you want to have that energy
and enthusiasm
10 20 years from now that you have today
and there's something unsustainable
about that extreme you know kind of
rigor of of pushing yourself in that way
that as somebody who's a little who's
older than you I can tell you uh at some
point you gotta find a new way yeah a
little bit of a new way well while
honoring that aspect of who you are and
I think like
my art helps me realize that because
you're digging into different facets of
society different people how they
operate and it's giving you that
self-reflective ability about what's
important what do you love how do you
address those inner demons like it's
really helping it's like your own form
of therapy so
um I know what's good for me and what
can pull me back and and we always do it
so you know for me it's definitely
spending time with my family I don't
have children myself and and that's been
something I've wrestled with like do I
do it or not and so spending time with
like nieces nephews brothers sisters
like making the effort even although
you're like I'm so busy I can't do it
well uh you know once you actually do it
you're like oh my God there's so much
joy and happiness that comes from that
so I think I know what you're talking
like I know where the edge of the cliff
is and I know the things that kind of
bring me back and they can't listen to
me yeah
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style in gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
[Music]
your partnership with your husband is
super interesting too because these this
is somebody that you met while out
riding you know another kind of
endurance Enthusiast who also is he a
neuroscientist also a psychologist he's
a psychologist yep PhD so brain
performance guy yeah turned like
screenwriter producer like that's a
that's like a very interesting pivot and
it's in its own right for him to kind of
shift his attention interest in
curiosity you know more in the direction
of of kind of where you were coming from
and this collaboration that you have
that goes kind of uncredited on his part
it seems like but you're always so far
yeah but now you have this big
production company yeah you've got all
these things going on and he's really
you know headlining that with me I think
it you know
again as an artifact of growing up in in
the UK right being British you're on a
track you do your undergraduate your
graduate your Master's your PhD your
postdoc you get your job and that's what
you're supposed to do it's the social
norm and then you get there and you
think oh him out I don't like it
like what the hell
and most people at that point they're
married maybe they've had children they
have a lot of Demands and they have a
lot of fear to take a jump
and I've spent my life taking jumps so
when Simon got to that point in his
career in Academia where he was hating
it I said babe give it up he's like stay
in your track position what but you know
probably most other partners would have
said oh but we've got the mortgage to
pay or what about the pension or such a
good job will you get anything again it
doesn't mean if you're not happy
so I've always been driven by that so
then he got out of it and of course he
spent his life writing albeit
academically writing but he you know
he's so creative and then when you're a
psychologist it's all about subtext of
people so then writing characters for
him just has been second nature so we
have this sort of amazing partnership
now where we come to the table with very
different skill sets I'm a lot more
macro I'm a lot more story structure
architecture character development
Concepts all the stuff I was trained in
at Uni and and then he's nitty-gritty
scenes getting in the world you know of
the dialogue he'll just like jump in it
so we have it's really wild after 20
years of marriage you just have so much
so much bloody fun I mean like we're
it's cool yay we're like bebopping
around and we've got a project set in
Ghana we just met the the king of
Ashanti in London oh wow
um in what world you're ought to be in
and we're like we both looked at each
other last week when we were meeting the
king and we're like it's hot you know
what
so it's it's a function of of of
cultivating and acting on that intuitive
voice right you talked about your life
being one of of taking these leaps right
and you probably get uh more used to
taking them the more that you take them
right and you know because it's worked
out like this is a good way for you to
follow your heart but what does that
look like for you when you have to make
a leap or a big decision how are you
checking in with yourself how is that
decision made what part of your
um
uh process involves like what the head
is telling you or the fears or the
insecurities or are you just like no
this is my I need to do this and even if
it doesn't make sense on paper this is
where I'm going my biggest fear in life
is missing out I have major formal so
that I did not take an opportunity I
don't care if I fail if I'm crap if it
doesn't pan out if I have not taken that
opportunity so that's actually what gets
me into trouble is do you know taking on
too much or you know yeah just always
trying to
you know be someone that is taking up
every opportunity you know I gotta get
obsessed with like that right so I don't
know how you like now I'm sure you're
shellacked with all kinds like you could
if you said yes to all the cool stuff
people are inviting you to you would
never get anything done
I'm not joking you know when I'm kind of
at that point where I'm like okay now I
need to say no
now I need to like focus on the task at
hand but luckily again I've had those
skills right from sport how do you
refine your your process how do you
figure out where you want to go and what
the steps are going to take you there
and I know where I want to go
so you have to always kind of check him
with the steps are going to get you
there right and sort of I think a lot of
the other a lot of the other stuff is
about ego and sort of what makes you
feel good or what's giving you a Pat in
the back or I I just I have a lot of
inherent confidence
like I I don't I don't I love being
stuff I know that sounds weird
and silly but it means that therefore I
can jump in and figure out how to get
better at it and the pursuit of that is
where I find my meaning and where I find
my joy that's so important to have that
beginner's mind and to not get caught up
in the perception of failure
because then you're
jumping into all different kinds of
things all the time and doing it for the
joy and the learning experience of it
rather than you know how people are
gonna perceive you if you don't do it
perfectly right
um
I'm curious where that comes from
because I think that's hard rot for a
lot of people
they don't want to try new things it's
just easier to keep doing the thing that
you're pretty good at or that people
kind of socially approve you for
I think it's the the love of suffering
and you can you know sort of assess that
any which way you will and interestingly
you know I've been digging into Victor
Frankel and man search for meaning for
another project and
I seek that I seek the suffering and
again I don't know if that's that
calvinistic you know the deficit model
you can't truly have joy if you haven't
had pain
and absolutely that has been my mantra
for life so I always seek the pain
whatever that looks like
uh yeah whether that's physical whether
that's mental and I don't mind if that
comes with not being good at something
do you feel when you're writing a
screenplay
that if you haven't bled on the page
that you haven't given it everything
that you have like is there a way to
create with ease or do you think
the best artistic spread expression that
you're capable of requires the level of
suffering and pain that is demanded from
Endurance Sports
I think that I guess I don't observe it
like that something is is is good or
it's not or you have a sense that it's
good or it's not or it's going to make
headwear it's not
[Music]
um
every single script is incredibly
difficult to write because we want our
our scripts to be layered with a lot of
depth which involves deep deep thought
on every single level
um whether that's the impact you know
what do you want the audience to feel
when they walk out the movie theater or
you know off their phone or however they
watch it and to to create that feeling
in an audience member takes so much
intricate
you know putting together of these
puzzles it's like a mathematical problem
uh to figure it out so some scripts are
definitely easier to write than others
and they just kind of come out even even
if they kind of come out they go through
so many different iterations you know
along the way once you get feedback from
your mentors once you get a director on
board once you get an actor on board
it's gonna go through all these
iterations and and and that's the beauty
of it you layer it and layer it and
layer it so the really truly great films
you know have this collaboration of all
of these wonderful minds and if you open
yourself up to that that's where the the
beauty of it comes the best idea wins
and the best ideas in a layered sense
are conveyed cinematically with great
intentionality but also incredible
efficiency you know so that they become
almost the backdrop so an example of
that in my mind would be in All Quiet on
the Western Front the recycling of the
uniforms that were introduced to in the
beginning like it barely it's not even
really you know in the Forefront of
what's actually happening but just the
process of seeing that says so much
about what's actually happening it's
it's it's the the entire theme of the
movie is built into that sequence right
so it's a genius device that happens
um
you know in a in a matter of seconds
right that's incredibly profound and and
stays with you and so that's not
something like the I however that idea
came about
um
is not something you could will into
being it's almost like a gift from the
Beyond right to discover to have that
Discovery and then translate that onto a
page and ultimately onto film and I
guess that's about preparing preparing
preparing so that you can let it go and
have it come to you and then it allows
itself to express and I'm sure it comes
to you when you're training right that's
the other thing like yeah like because
then you're in that space of that
there's something about the breath and
the elevated heart rate that creates
vacancy or space in your mind for that
inspiration to come totally uh and I'm
thinking I'm trying to imagine you
because I know what I do when you're out
and you're in the middle of a session
and you have something like that hits
how do you capture that because I know
what it's like to say I got it and then
at the end of the session I've forgotten
the idea do you stop and write it down
in a note do you record a voice memo do
you just repeat it to yourself so you
don't forget it sometimes sometimes it's
just a feeling
so it might not be as concrete As
Natural idea so sometimes it's just a
sense of something
and then I percolate that sense and then
come up with an idea so maybe I'll use a
whole run I get a sense or something and
then I start to like Bounce Around okay
what about this what about that well I
need to do this but what about and it
just evolves and I let it evolve and
then once it's done that then I'll kind
of okay oh my God pull over in the car
or whatever
you know or I'll be you know in the
middle of a gym workout or I'll be up
the side of a mountain you know calling
Simon
you know
um yeah so it's it's again sort of
preparing your mind
enough to be able to let it go and that
means watching a lot reading a lot
understanding what you need out of a
scene like an opening scene for example
is so important you know it captures as
you said the the essence the Thematic
essence of what you're trying to say in
this film so it's very very important
but you want to do it in a way that
isn't what we call on nose you're not
directly saying it you're indirectly
saying it but then you've got the
parameters of the story that you're
telling so for all quiet for example we
knew we wanted to start in the
battlefield because it was really
important to give the audience a sense
of this is a world that you're going to
be a part of for the next you know two
and a half hours
but our main character Paul we needed
him still to be at home to be caught up
in the Patriotic verva that was a really
important part of the story so you're
like okay so we need to start out in the
battlefield but then we need to track
and come back home how do we do that you
know so you start to put all of these
kind of pieces together and then bit by
bit you know you figure it out and
interestingly I figured that piece out
because I just watched Schindler's List
um and there's a sequence in there with
a girl with a red coat right where the
whole film is in black and white and
there's this girl in this red coat and
you see her you know sort of walking
around and then of course you see her
body in the striker and it was so
beautiful and heart-wrenching and that's
you know so I watch a lot I read a lot I
think about those parameters and then
boom something will come and then you
build on that right so for example uh Ed
or director Edward Berger uh he's a
co-writer uh on the script hole so he
elevated it even more by the end of the
sequence where you follow the uniform
back
um and uh the tag is taken off
the tag is dropped on the ground along
with loads of others that wasn't and
that you know that wasn't in our
original script so all the time you're
getting these Concepts elevated by both
a scriptwriter there are core script
writers the director and then you've got
the music then you've got the
cinematography all these layers of
meaning which just add up and it's the
same as sport all of these different
layers that you're building on you know
to create this performance and to create
this film so it just makes sense in my
head
how one helps the other
that's fascinating and inspiring but we
haven't even gotten to the really
compelling you know aspect of this story
uh which is the grit and the
perseverance and the determination and
the patience
that you demonstrated
to birth this project to the screen so
in the timeline of your life we're only
at rugby in ballet come on right you
know we don't have nine hours we have
plenty of time but basically you get
into running fell running after that you
find your way via your dad into
Triathlon you have a lot of success
um pretty quickly out of the gate as a
triathlete you pursue it in college
and despite your success you realize
like you're just not gonna you're just
kind of a rung shy of the Commonwealth
game slash Olympic Team Caliber in this
itu world of draft legal and where you
have to be you know really fast as a
swimmer which is not your main thing
which disheartens you from the sport and
you ultimately I don't know why I'm
telling your story you should be telling
it but I'm trying to get to the
beginning part you know this this lead
you to kind of Step Back From sport for
a while you come out to San Diego with
Simon am I on the timeline right and you
get your Masters in theater and you're
going to pursue this career on the arts
initially as an actor right which was
bananas and again that was like you know
facing your fears on this you know we go
from Scotland and all of a sudden you're
in Hollywood doing auditions for
directors albeit you know for small
films and student films and so on
um
but I had so much joy in that period of
my life because I was so disappointed at
being a failure in sport or at least not
feeling like it wasn't even about
realizing my potential it said I'd lost
my passion
so again I'll come back to sort of
finding joy in the process of what I'm
doing and the Mastery of The Craft
and I'd lost that with Triathlon because
I'd been funneled down a path that
didn't suit me into a sport that didn't
suit me that I didn't find joy in and I
didn't think there was any other way to
do it and it wasn't until I came out to
California and got into the Arts again
that I rekindled oh my God I'm really
passionate about this ah oh my God I
really love it I'm so excited I can't
sleep because I just want to get up and
do it you know and what a gift because
most athletes upon retirement I mean
let's face it you know it's only the the
rare few that make it to the Olympic
team it's interesting that you
characterized that aspect of your career
as a failure you did great you just
weren't going to go to that next level
that very few get to right so I would
consider that a success but that aside
um in retirement
it's very rare for that individual to
recapture the passion that they had in
sport in some other field right and it's
super fascinating when you look at
athletes and how many suffer from deep
depression yeah anxiety there's a lot of
you know High suicide rates post
athletic career because you've had such
Focus because you've had such drive and
you know and then you've lost that you
know where's your purpose and meaning
and that's why I've always kindled these
two separate pieces of my life that have
given me equal drawing different ways
and never let any one of them go and
anytime I do let one go too much or one
is elevated too much I actually kind of
like don't become a good person in a way
like I'm very very challenged I need to
keep some semblance of both going yeah
yeah so I think coming back to studying
a masters being in a different world
getting to sort of you know reinvent
myself and Calif fornia and do crazy
acting like you know horror films
get eaten in the half by a chupacabra
but you do some like slashes oh my God
Rich buddy can we find that yes you can
it's super embarrassing like Roger
Corman type stuff it's it's it's like
you know Naf American accent you know
like stupid blonde girl giggling you
know I even at one point
had to yeah I had to imagine getting
eaten in half and I was like tied up and
I had to like give this big scream and
I'm thinking God
but you know it was it was just it was
so fun it was so ridiculous it was fun I
felt like I was living in a movie you
know literally
um yeah and then just the relationships
I developed through that you know I felt
like it was fueling my soul because the
pursuit of endurance sport can be a very
sort of myopic thing it's you know you
become very self-centered and you know
kind of numb emotionally
um and this just opened my world up
again and that's what I mean by if one
takes off too much then I'm in trouble
because if I become too ethereal too
emotional I don't I like the discipline
if I become too you know obsessive
compulsive sports like structure
structure structure I lose my sense of
soul and being so it's like I always
have to have bits of bits above but um
yeah so then I think by finding myself
again by finding passion again I then
started and I vowed I would never do
another Triathlon again no joke when I
came to California I'm like I'm not
doing that sport it's really
stupid it's really crazy what the hell I
was like watching a couple of buddies
race
here are those idiots Flash Forward you
know you're in San Diego which is like
the mecca of all of our videos right
were you in the north county or were you
like in the city down I was in the
sinful South yeah it's like nobody from
the north goes you know further south
all the way Triathlon Geeks live up in
the north yeah they do and once you're
accepted in that you know click
then you know your eyes still off the
heights but um yeah so it was like I was
in this place it was known for Triathlon
and I wasn't doing it but then I kind of
got the bug again and I got into
cross-country running and I started to
meet some really cool people and I was
just like really ambivalent about it
really just getting back to enjoying it
and being fit again and what that felt
like
and then I phoned Xterra which is all
off-road Triathlon I was like oh my God
this is like rugby plus Triathlon equals
extero this is amazing
so and I felt those butterflies in my
stomach like oh my God and I was like
I'm gonna give this a shot and that was
kind of it I did my first one and I
remember I was racing against Michaela
Jones and a bunch of other big names and
I was right up there and I'm like ah I
think I've just read my sport was that
the one that you you went back to
Scotland and you just jumped in on a
race and won it or something like that
or did that that or was that the
lightning bolt that was the only thing
that told you oh this world of exterior
is like where I should be yeah that was
it and then you came back and you know
you just start absolutely
crushing it and you win three World
titles in Xterra right like 2011 12 and
18. right yeah
um and then two other world
championships in like offer I don't even
know what that is
just the two different governing bodies
so itu has its own off-road Triathlon
governing body called itu crosstraforms
so they have their own events so it's
like just two different governing bodies
so
yeah that has been a crazy ride man
that's been a crazy ride
simultaneously
you make this decision
when was it 2006 2008 that you are going
to option this book written in 1929
right called All Quiet on the Western
Front that we all read in school
a lot of us of my generation saw the
1979 TV movie there's the 1930 movie
that won the Oscar right this is not a
hot property for some reason you decide
to aim your focus on this project so
let's start with what struck you about
this book and convinced you that this
was worthy of your investment of not
only time and energy but significant
resources yeah a lot of a lot of Miller
um so it was interesting so as I got
into the film world and I was acting I
met my co-writer on this project Ian
stokel and we teamed up and he said
listen Liz if you want to be an actor
you really have to write and produce
your own stuff if you know you want to
go far enough because then you have some
kind of control over what you're doing
and that really made sense to me again
thinking outside the box about how to
expressly since there's such a strong
female lead in all quiet in the Western
Front
hey man we had a whole other story like
that I had a great view already
drops there were this project over 16
years but go ahead and so well so then
we started writing scripts together
because I'd not written before and I was
learning the craft and and kind of
enjoying it and then we were both
reading this book and I don't know what
possessed us but we wondered who had the
rights of the book because here's the
thing when you're a writer or a producer
and you're very much on the outside you
don't really have connections you don't
have an agent you don't none of that
you have to do something that's going to
set yourself apart and certainly in this
industry now it's all about intellectual
property IEP if you have some kind of Ip
that's a worth that's something that's
going to set you apart from everyone
else knocking on doors so we were
reading this book it was like a sale at
Barnes and Noble and Ian's like gosh I
wonder who has the rights and we both
love war films I mean I love Saving
Private Ryan I love Apocalypse Now these
are all films I watch and watch and
watch and watch because it's such War
films like they're this Amazing Canvas
at its most extreme to really
investigate character and so World War
One at that time had really not been
done and it's there's so much tragedy
but so much Beauty it's like this alien
landscape that visually is so arresting
that I was I was absolutely drawn to
that like gosh we need a modern
retelling of this story so we went about
you know going to the estate of the
author well first of all you would
assume that some studio has it tied up
just for the purpose of not letting
anyone else make it correct yeah and as
much as it didn't seem like a big title
that's a big title everybody knows about
it if if it has that kind of
recollection that means it's worth
something so Universal had just let it
Labs so we jumped in we made a bid we
pleaded our case we said this is how we
want to do it and they said okay we're
like what the hell so that was like oh
my God we've made it oh right and just
for people who are listening or watching
who don't understand what that means as
a former entertainment lawyer who did a
million option agreements you are
purchasing an option on the property
which means you are paying for the
exclusive right within a given period of
time to buy the book to make the movie
the option is
a relatively nominal fee in comparison
to the purchase price it's basically
saying no one else can buy this during
this period of time except us and for
that right we will pay you X and in your
case it was like 15 to 20 grand a year
was it where you were doing yearly
annual renewal sometimes it was 12
months sometimes it was 18 right it was
about 10 000 to 15 000.
um which you know seems nominal to Epic
Studio which it is but to your everyday
you know husband's an academic earning
not very much you're a professional
triathlete like what
um it was a lot of money it was a lot of
money yeah you're you're a student
you're right out you're this is during
school or right when you got out of when
your mouse yeah I was just um yeah so
who's got 10 15 grand lying around to
have to just say I have the right to
shop this thing
I mean I was working on a bike shop
for minimum wage you know what I mean so
like
but there was something about it that
and and really Ian taught me this is you
have to take risks you have to take a
gamble you have to go for something if
you really believe in it and so we
thought well why not just give it a go
you know if this is what's going to set
us apart and give us a step up on the
ladder
and a yay that was what we thought as
soon as we got it I remember signing the
paper we faxed it would you believe
that's how long ago it was I remember
getting the facts through and be like oh
my God yeah we thought that's it we've
made it you know and then of course you
have to adapt the thing which by
the way is incredibly difficult
um because when you're taking a text
like that that was written so long ago
you know it certainly wasn't written
cinematically I mean it's beautiful it's
poetic thematically there's so much
there but it's like excerpts of a diary
and that's what you know is a screenplay
light writer you're looking for some
kind of Direction some kind of structure
to hang it on some kind of narrative
through the line
so that still respects the the essence
of the book how do you do that so that
took multiple drafts do you go back and
watch the 1979 version
or do you avoid those like you want to
learn like from just a curiosity
forensic perspective like how did they
structure it and watching that after
being so familiar with the book you
would get a sense of how they figured
out what to focus on to create a
narrative out of this series of diary
entries so we watched everything and
anything we read everything and anything
that we could we did as much research as
we could
and then looking at the current
landscape of film uh what audiences
respond to what did we feel was
important how were we going to elevate
this because one of the biggest
questions was always going to be well
why do this again why is it important
why now and that's a question that we
come back to in all of our projects why
is this relevant now and if you can't
answer that and answer it authentically
and effectively then don't do it what
was your answer to that then I know the
answer now yep so then it was really
about the Betrayal of a youthful
generation
because
that for me wrong true because
I'm Scottish I'm of that Underdog
mentality where you're fighting against
what you deem to be that upper brass
so I could really relate to being
manipulated by something up here
so I love that aspect of it so betrayal
felt really potent and that's something
that we we dug into right from the
get-go
and then for us like I'm really
fascinated by history in general but but
also how we manipulate history depending
on which side you're on so once we dug
into things like the reparations that
Germany had to pay after World War One
the signing of the Armistice all of
these different aspects of the story it
was fascinating I'm like we're not
taught any of this
and of course the book was written when
World War II had not occurred so how to
update it is to give it some kind of
historical context
that that gives you an understanding of
how World War One caused World War II
which I think is really critical in
understanding how do we prevent things
in the future what does this mean how
can we have you know how can we teach
our audience in some way about what the
future can hold sure yeah
yeah I'm wondering whether that pitch at
that time was sufficient enough to
convince anyone to say yes we're doing
this because when I think about the
moment when the movie came out it seemed
to make so much more sense it was very
current and relatable in the context of
what was happening in the Ukraine and it
was constructed on the shoulders of a
couple developments in Hollywood that
suddenly made the movie make sense the
first being the the explosion of
streaming which created more outlets for
production and distribution the
um acceptance of foreign language Cinema
as as a mainstream art by dint of movies
like parasite and then thirdly the
success of 1917 of course right which
opened up the oh these movies work
people do care about this period of time
right none of which you could have
scripted or imagined no they came about
um in the process this 16-year journey
that you went on to like get this movie
made but in 2006 7 8 when you're trying
to get this thing up on its feet and
you're knocking on doors what is the
response that you're getting I mean were
you going in thinking of course they're
going to want to make this movie or
everybody knows this book right totally
well like our classic saying we should
have got t-shirts well why wouldn't they
that was why wouldn't they
um you know I think there were still
some World War One movies coming out you
know that we thought Like A Very Long
Engagement and things like that and we
thought well you know maybe we've got a
chance I mean it was just about finding
the right person at the right time and
film is a weird one it's just it's all
about timing and you can't predict when
that timing is going to happen you just
have to straight stay true to your
intention and why it's important to tell
why you feel it is and then that's going
to keep you going and so our path took
us down crazy Journeys so like at the
start of this we thought we were going
to do it as English language with German
accents because 16 years ago you could
not yeah you couldn't do it in German
language no way so we're like okay then
you start looking at the the business
side of it and you say to get film off
the ground you need either a big
director so we went to a lot of big
German directors who all turned it down
you know a lot of German directors were
scared of the material yeah like there's
there's not a lot of upside in touch in
that material unless you get it exactly
right which you know I believe Ed did
um but he was so passionate he knew his
vision right from the get-go what he
wanted to do
um and we hadn't find that and then it
was okay so we try and get a big cast
member right that's kind of fun the film
no it's not so um we went to Daniel
Radcliffe this is way back at the start
which was kind of bananas we managed to
reach out to him and we got a meeting
with him and we flew overnight X we
couldn't afford a hotel and he was
living in New York we're like okay we'll
get a cheap flight overnight we rock up
to his apartment thinking is he gonna
like is this really happening
um you know which app on the door and he
flipping answers
Harry Potter answers the door we're like
what's going on so we rock into his
apartment he's getting his Cup cities
peanuts are in the back Mom Dad stay
back there we're like we're 34. and he's
just around like his echus yes he was
massive yeah he was on Broadway then
yeah yeah exactly and he has a big
apartment in New York and so he was like
I love your guys script that's it I want
to come on board we're like oh my God so
my claim to fame is that you know I
dropped one in Harry Potter's toilet
yeah so that's it
scene in the biopic stays in that's
right exactly
um you guys didn't have any money right
like what was nothing yeah nothing so
but then you realize you have to learn
the business like what how do you put a
film together how does that work and we
quickly realized that Daniel Radcliffe
was not going to get it off the ground
because outside of Harry Potter it
wasn't worth anything
um and then of course his agency didn't
want him attached to something that
wasn't getting made so then it came off
it so you're learning all of this about
the business as you go on and you're
trying to sort of strategize and how do
we knock on those doors how do we get
those attachments how do we this how do
that we've got different producers on
board one of which went to jail
um I mean you couldn't right but you
haven't really paid your dues in
Hollywood trying to get a movie made
unless one of your producers goes to
jail at some point totally right so
embezzlement or something like that it
was Belgium Belgium embezzlement
and from some Insurance Fund or
something totally yeah
and then we've just we've just had some
crazy meetings you know like I remember
going in to meet this producer and I kid
you not when I see his office he had a
stage and he had a throne on the stage
and that was like I'm not joking that
was like his office are you gonna name
names I can't even remember who it was
it was that long ago and then we've met
other directors you know where you're
walking and I remember this one director
and and I remember walking in and his
assistant went and this is you know and
pronounce the name I'm thinking what
anyway so that but you know you have to
kind of see each experiences something
in and of itself and even if the film
doesn't get made we never would have had
those kind of opportunities right you're
learning as you go about how things
actually work right and you were doing
that without representation yeah you
have you didn't have an agency yeah
opening any of those doors for you and
the ticking clock much like the
Armistice in the background of all quiet
so we have the ticking clock of the
option you've got to come up with this
money every 12 to 18 months and the way
to do that is to win World Championships
right so while you're pursuing this
movie body training six seven hours a
day and then showing up and crushing it
there's two stories that I want you to
tell from this period the 2000 no it was
the 2011 Xterra and Maui championships
yeah my first world title yeah so so
there's that story and then obviously
there's the Costa Rica story but start
let's start with Mallory I think the
isn't that that's so important is that
it it changed the course of my life
because when you've been in pursuit of
something like winning a world title or
being the best in the world or an
Olympic title whatever that is and
you're faced with Incredible odds and
then you overcome that because you just
keep going
it changes everything about what you
have to do if you want to succeed at
something that specific race I came out
the water in pole position I was a
fittest I'd ever been I was like oh my
God today's it today is the day and you
don't get that feeling often where all
the stars are aligning and I got on my
bike and I rolled out of transition and
I had a flat tire
I was like are you kidding me
I've never had a flat tire at a race
before like what and so everyone's
passing me and I just remember this
moment thinking
I can either throw in the towel and just
like succumb woes me never meant to be
or I can say you know what I'm gonna
fight because I'm fit I'm in a beautiful
place like why not why not like you know
at least I'll get a workout and then I
can have some you know freaking ice
cream and not feel guilty about it
so um I I fix a puncture and I bike and
I just keep going and I make it up into
fourth position on the bike but I am 10
minutes down on the leader with only a
sorry she changed the flat you didn't
ride on so I changed the flat so it was
what happened was the tire pressure was
so low on my sometimes on mountain
biking in order to get traction you have
loads you want it low yeah so it was too
low so it burped the tire so I then had
to get my canister and pop it so that it
popped not that I knew that at the time
but after a few stop and goes and
figuring it out I realized that what it
was that's what it was I heard a pop and
I'm oh my God I'm on my way so I cycle I
just keep on going I'm feeling great and
I'm like well it and I cycle up to
Fourth but I'm I think it was six and a
half minutes down
um on the leader with a 10K to go
and I'm like well air for an attitude
just give it everything you have and I
climb my way back up to second I
remember being at the top of the hill on
the specific course and I saw a
helicopter come over
Mike holy that means a leader is
really close so I'm barreling down this
hill and I see the leader of Melanie
McQuaid in front of me and she's
stumbling around I'm like ah oh my God
I'm gonna pass her
so I pass her with literally I think I
don't know it was maybe a key to go half
a mile to go or something like that and
she ends up collapsing and not finishing
the race
and
I just remember like Simon's face he's
like waking up he's so happy and I just
thought I could have given up
I could have not bought I could have
thrown in the towel
and that really just it changed
everything for me to just keep going so
three pieces of information you left out
which is first of all that prize money
allowed you to extend the option yes
secondly you you ran 43.54 uh which was
the same as the men's winner Michael
Weiss yep who is like Elite like that
guy is a you know a beast right so he
ran just as fast as the men's winner and
for context your run split was 10
minutes faster than Lance Armstrong who
was competing in that race
yeah screw it Lance how's about there my
Apple's body
uh that's unbelievable
you go on to you know win a bunch of
races uh you won in 2012 also but then
you have this when does the the Lyme
disease situation kick in socially
interesting that was like 2013 so 2012
when I won for the second time it it's
interesting because any athlete will
tell you the first time is Elation but
it's quickly followed by the doubt and
Thomas's where I don't deserve this I'm
not really that good you know it was all
questionable Melanie mcquated collapsed
can I do it again
and I went through a period of just like
oh my God I'm not that good and I
quickly brought on my husband and we
figured out how do I you know get better
how do I make this happen again so 2012
I started with not getting a flat that
starts with not but it starts with your
essence of like why you're doing it like
the beauty of it like what's important
to you and I remember that summer of the
thing that got me ready for 2012 was my
training bodies I had the best Partners
in the world and we had this wonderful
friendship and I had so much joy in my
training and that took me to this world
at the second world title and that was
the best race in my life no doubt about
it that was that to this day every
single piece of it was perfect every
piece of my dad was there watching and
he was not there in 2011. did he give it
up for you he did he did man he got glad
you got it from him he got so pissed
that night it was amazing and anytime my
dad gets pissed as in drunk you know I
always ask him for money so you'll give
hahaha so I'm like all right pops give
me the money for the auction
um no but uh yeah so that was 2012 and
then after that I think I just kind of
dug myself a hole you know when you've
you've found this moment where you've
achieved what you deemed to be a real
greatness
and then you are searching for it again
it takes you down some dark Paths of
that obsessive personality so I lost a
lot of weight I just like really
compromised my immune system and then
um all of these symptoms started to
arise and that's when I realized I had
chronic Lyme's disease
and that set me on this path that was
awful
um yeah so I went from being the best in
the world and getting the fastest
runtime split to oh now you're in bed
and you can't get out and you're in
chronic pain
so the leveling of that I think that's
where now dealing with failure I
couldn't give a toss because having gone
from the highest high to lowest lows you
have so much gratitude for being able to
do anything
that you don't care whether it's good or
it's bad you just want to be doing it
how long were you bedridden like what
was that Discovery and recovery process
like
um years really it was years
um I never really got over it
um I because with Lyme's disease it's
really curious because
your body cannot fight it off because
there's many other things going on
so you have to figure out all of the
different things going on in your system
that has created this perfect storm for
you not to be able to recover from it
and that's when I embarked on my what we
call my investigative Health hustle
which is I'm gonna stop at nothing to
figure out what's going on so I spoke to
every doctor every therapist went all
over the world
um and at that time I was also suffering
from chronic pain chronic pelvic pain
which meant I couldn't sit down I could
only lie down I couldn't drive anywhere
I had to have someone drive me to places
all the while I'm still trying to
compete I'm still trying to speak to
sponsors to get money so you're trying
to grit and train your way through it oh
it's awful it was the pelvic pain
related to the Lyme disease or that was
a separate thing no it was kind of
related
um it was understanding kind of what my
body was dealing with it was exposed to
a lot of toxicity it was exposed to mold
toxicity and some heavy metals and
various other things I had a lot of gut
problems I'd had a lot of antibiotics a
lot of sugars a lot of I mean my body
was a mess right it was just a mess and
um and that all led to this kind of
chronic inflammation and certainly If
you experience mold toxicity which you
know is relatively unknown pelvic pain
is one of the the major symptoms because
the pulling of the toxicity the
mycotoxins from the mold they actually
pull in your urethra in your kind of
around your urine and around that bowl
that pelvic Bowl where all those nerve
ends are so I had both
um biomechanical issues that were
creating like high hamstring
tendinopathy but then at the same time
this chronic
neural inflammation in this area caused
by mold I mean how would I ever have
known any of them yeah I'm wondering how
you even came to that diagnosis with
pelvic pain being the primary
symptomology I mean mold would not be on
the list of the top 100 causal well it
took me
eight and a half years to get to that
point so it was eight and a half years
of chronic pain and at some points so
debilitating I'd go to bed at night
crying and wake up wishing that it it
would be okay in the morning
so you know
um and once I got to the point and I've
only been out of pain for about a year
and a half wow which is wild and and in
fact at my last outing I went I had the
spot pad everyone knows me it's really
funny I have this like it's totally
minging as in like grotty foamy thing
that I have to sit on anytime I go
anywhere and it was this running joke
are you gonna take it to the Oscars you
know you're going to be in a red carpet
who's going to be holding your butt pads
oh my God
and I think it was two weeks ago I went
out on a day of meetings in in London
and I went without my butt pad and I sat
on hard chairs and I sat in a tube and
there was no issues
so it's just amazing that like you deal
with all this adversity and the
gratitude that comes out of the simple
things like sitting on a tube and the
the healing the recovery from the mold
and the lime
what did that entail like once it was
diagnosed and you were on a certain
protocol towards getting better what did
that mean it's ongoing because once
you've experienced such
toxicity and so many issues in your body
it's like peeling back layers of the
onion to figure out how to get over it
and it's very expensive I mean if you
work with any what we call functional
medicine doctors root cause medicine
doctors
you know you're paying out a pocket
largely and it's thousands I mean just
to get tested is Thousands let alone the
treatment and then okay so you're
exposed to mold well most houses have
more than them you know and then you
have a genetic component which means
that if you have this specific Gene
you're more susceptible to being
impacted by it so not everyone is so how
do you explain that to people you know
then you're renting an apartment that
has molds somewhere how do you test for
it it's like ten thousand bucks then
okay you find you've got mold in your
house
how do you remediate it that's I don't
know 25 Grand so do you know what I mean
it's like all of these it's a very
frustrating process
but at least the knowledge and the
awareness of what's going on helps you
deal with the symptomology that you're
going through right right right wow I
didn't realize it was that severe acute
and and prolonged oh yeah and it can
cause extreme if you're if you're
exposed to it chronically
um and again it's like this perfect
storm there's other stuff going on in
your system
um then you know various symptoms
anxiety panic attacks depression can be
huge huge factors so and Simon being a
scientist that he is he was quite
um he didn't really believe in it I
guess I would say and then we realized
that we were both working beside a unit
in our old house that once we ripped it
out it had black mold everywhere and he
was suffering from you know pretty
extreme anxiety that had gotten worse
and worse and worse so there's it's just
gosh I mean we could go to it
that's like a whole podcast in and of
itself like spent hours on that I'm sure
when you move now the first thing you're
doing is like doing the mold analysis
before it's like oh for God's sake wow
so so so during this period so this the
onset of this is 2013 around yeah so
while this is going on you're like three
years into this right
um still trying to train still trying
trying to keep the option alive the
dream alive trying to function in the
world
and in was it 2015 or 2016 you go to
Costa Rica to compete in this race broke
desperate for the win because the option
lapse is on the horizon and there's just
no
um negotiation here like you need that
money totally and I just come off the
back of a lot of illness so I was coming
back to racing so I had that fire in the
ballet to want to do well and you were
on an upswing an upswing and I'm like
I'm gonna go out to this race I'm gonna
win it a I'm feeling great trending his
for the first time in a long time gone
really well and the day before the race
is an off-road Triathlon you wrecky the
course right you check out where the
oldest hands where are the Rocks all
that good stuff so I go out on a
pre-ride like the day before and I fall
off my bike and I'm like wow that really
hurts
come to find out I've broken my shoulder
did not know that then all I knew is I
could not lift up my arm
and uh
and I was like I was devastated you know
lots of Tears lots of oh my God not only
are we going to lose the auction because
this is our only way to pay it and like
through this whole Health Journey you
finally have a glimpse of feeling okay
enough to raise and I'm just like what
so I quickly went out on the bike and I
kind of propped up my hand and I'm like
well you know what I can hold on with my
right and I can probably steer the
course isn't very technical
maybe I can ride my bike running that
was actually okay because of where I
broke my shoulder the up and down motion
was actually okay then I was like went
down to the water's edge with Simon I'm
like can I swim
could not lift up my arm I mean not one
iota I couldn't put a bobble on couldn't
get my brown I was like a bubble what's
a bobble
a bubble uh for your you know like a Wii
oh like a hair tie a haircut
cut through the Scottish you know
um so I go down the water's edge and
Simon looks at me and he's like well you
know you're really good at the one arm
drill
I'm like you know he's right because I
spent so much time when I was younger
trying to figure out how to swim that we
do a bunch of drills I was really good
at one arm drill so I'll go in the water
and I'm like wow I can count it Maybe
and I thought well what's what's the
worst that can happen you start the race
you go out 50 meters and you come back
big deal I might as well start right
it's that whole let's take one step and
see what what happens so I get into the
water and it's an ocean swim so I get
through the waves with one arm and I'm
checking like nobody's business
and it's really tiring right on your
legs and you've got to ride and run oh
totally and I'm like
you know and everyone's
everyone's everyone's overtaking me and
of course everyone annoys me is a
freaking former world champion
so Simon's on the beach she's taking a
video and someone like someone goes God
he sees me off the back and he says hey
don't let anyone any anyone in the Pro
field these days won't they and Simon's
chuckling to himself no one is me so I
come out the water I make it through um
you know 1500 meters with one arm so I'm
pooped
and I get on I get on a bike and just
going through a transition with one
arm's difficult but I can't imagine I
get on a bike and I have to carry my
bike down any of The Descendants but I
start making ground
and I make my way up to second position
on a bike and then of course my running
is my strongest
and I run three times okay you just
brush through the fact that you rode
through the entire field all the way up
into second with a broken shoulder after
doing the swim leg with one arm it's
true I was I think it was 12 minutes 12
minutes down
so you made up 12 minutes I made up 12
minutes of course I think it was about I
made up like I don't know 10 minutes or
nine minutes on the bike
so and then go on the run and
run through to the wind and it was like
that was it oh yeah so you win this race
with a broken shoulder yep you're
swimming with one arm yep and uh get the
prize money renew the option this is the
story that Hollywood loves this is a
story that got recycled in every profile
piece about you around the Oscars you
know this is like the key moment in the
hero's journey you know biopic of of
Leslie oh totally and it was and it's
funny because when you're in it you
don't really think about it you just
I've built a career on just trying to
take the next step forward and don't
forget it come from such Devastation of
being at the Pinnacle of something that
I truly love I mean I'm a runner at
heart I love it to then not being able
to do it and just dreaming about doing
it of any shape or form for years
and then getting on a start line I'm
like I'm not gonna lie a broken shoulder
wear me down you know I'm gonna make
this happen whatever it takes so
you know I think when you've come from
that you know you just you find a way
it's an incredible story and you're 10
years in to the journey of trying to get
this movie made right
how do you how did you remain undaunted
and unrelenting was there a moment where
you thought are we really going to renew
this option again like let's move on
like clearly the town does not want this
project there's plenty of ideas out
there we can work on that might not
involve us spending a bunch of money on
an old book that that doesn't exactly
lend itself to cinema in the way that
maybe we misjudged you know do you know
what you're so driven by a need to tell
a story and I felt like this angle that
we had was so unique I knew we just had
to find the right person
and Hollywood is littered with stories
so this took us 10 years this took us
eight years this took us 12 years
whatever and I thought to myself this is
our chance we can't give up on a chance
but then also reconciling that in your
head and saying
is this about the journey or is this
about the destination
and so it was opening doors and it was
giving us something because we were
still able to get meetings with people
based on the fact that we had the
options the rights of all quiet people
are intrigued like these no-name writers
have that option like what the so
we just saw this almost like a business
venture this is giving us opportunity
just like you invest in your business we
are investing like that so don't think
so much about whether this phone was
going to get made or not you're seeing
it as an opportunity to develop the
connections and open doors that you
couldn't have had open beforehand and
that was a mindset it's all about
mindset right kind of growth mindset
right so what was the inflection point
that led to it getting made was it
meeting Burger
it was it was all very circuitous and
weird and complicated so we had another
producer that was helping us at the time
and through various connections of his
like five times removed
Edward Berger got the script along with
his producing partner Malta Grenier
and they reached out to us and we were
kind of tied up with other people at the
time so it all got very complicated but
they reached out and said we love your
script would you guys consider doing
this in German
and of course we always had but it would
never have been possible before and Ed's
Vision along with that idea we were like
oh my God so we had to quickly get out
of the arrangement that we were in
which was very expensive and very
stressful and then we embarked on a on a
journey with these guys and it was
when something feels so right you
realize how wrong everything felt
beforehand
and when we we got involved with with Ed
and Malta it was like everything
happened you know they say the overnight
success but it truly is like that when
everything is right in Hollywood like it
when people aren't returning your calls
it's because it's not right right
because if it was they'd be calling you
on a Saturday I don't care if it's their
kids soccer game or not if they want it
they'll call you then
so that's kind of how it was with us
everything came together at the right
time and then everything happened really
quickly yep what's interesting about
that is
despite all of that like you see the
movie It's Exquisite I mean I haven't
even like showered you with praise for
like how much I love the movie like it's
just it's gorgeous It's haunting it
stays with you it's so eloquently
beautifully rendered every detail is is
so thoughtfully and intentionally you
know
um
positioned to you know evoke the
emotional response that you're trying to
get out of the audience like I I just
and you know what I didn't watch it
right away because I was like
this move you know like it kind of
popped out of nowhere it wasn't in the
theaters and suddenly it's on Netflix
and you know no one was really talking
about it until suddenly everyone was
talking about it and even then it took a
while for me to say all right I'm going
to take the time to watch it and then
you see it and you're like oh my God
it's nothing like what I because you pre
because we have this relationship with
this property in this book right we
project onto it some baggage about when
we read it in high school or whatever it
is
um but
it's so artfully made down to the finest
detail and yet
on every level it does defy all of those
hardened laws of Hollywood right you
need an A-list Star right you need a
A-list director you got to come in you
know with the agency in a big package
and you're going to go to the studios
and there's going to be the theatrical
release and the marketing campaign and
you have none of that totally none of it
I mean
um you know Burger's direction is
unbelievable but and he didn't even he
had some like a few credits and he'd
done some television
um but he's not Ridley Scott and then
you find this kid Felix the whole movie
rests on this kid's ability to carry it
totally if that kid doesn't work the
movie doesn't work somehow you find this
unknown
um person who's never starred in a movie
before and you know
just shoulders that film with such
pathos with this face that you know
tells you everything you need yeah it's
like I'm like how is how do all of these
things come together in this way to make
this work and it's like on Netflix
totally in a foreign language I know I
know I think it all starts with
intention and it all starts with passion
I think that that both are script and
then adds
clear clear passion
about how we wanted to tell the story
and why he felt it was important and
every single frame of that film is
imbued with that
and
it's such an important piece to the to
German culture and what it represents
the sense of shame that Germans feel
about any kind of War
the fact that they cannot view war in
any kind of heroic sense
is so unique and so compelling
that that elevated the material above
anything that you see out there
and and so
you know I really think that it takes
it takes and and the interesting thing
is Ed is a director
as soon as we we got this email from him
I reached out to a few people that I
know in the industry and said you know
how is he viewed in the industry because
we're very much on the outside we didn't
we don't really know because there's
like this whole Inner Circle of like
who's talking about her that if you're
on the outside you have no idea
so I reached out to a few folk that kind
of knew and they were like oh my God he
is like Mega hot property right now
he was like he was always about to pop
even though he didn't have this body of
work behind him so he's about to pop
then you have this a amazing producer
Malta who's done a lot of very quality
work
and then we presented it and then you
have like you know it's European Netflix
which is operates very differently we
had Sasha Bueller ahead of of European
Netflix championing the project so you
have all of these individuals that
combined make this epic quality and then
it's all about authenticity it's all
about bringing on the right people at
every single level
to make sure that this is going to be
the best film you've ever seen and you
know the attention to detail I mean when
they cast Felix he went through rounds
of additions even although Edward knew
he was right from the get-go
he pushed him I don't know he was like
there was a relationship somebody knew
him and he was in a theater group or
something like that well it was our
producer's wife that works in theater
and he was a a quite a well-known
theater a theater actor or at least you
know making making noises and
you know and some of the additions for
example they dressed them all in his
uniform to see how he would walk you
know to see how he would you know embody
this character and every step of the way
he was pushed and he was pushed and he
came up and he came up and then Edward
was like yep he is our guy because he's
going to be on set hours and hours and
hours a day and pushed emotionally and
physically to limit I mean his uniform
and he'd come off a day of shooting was
a hundred pounds yeah I read that
somewhere yeah you weighed the uniforms
I mean school like just absorbing all
the water and the water and it was it
was cold it was muddy it was and then it
was an incredibly emotional shoot I mean
think some of those scenes and what it
means to people and how impactful they
are you know I mean gosh
so anyways I just think it what it what
it tells me as well is so many young
people have watched this movie and
responded to it that people are ready
for Content that matters that has that
kind of depth
but it all starts with story
and unfortunately that can often get
lost
and we're in the midst of a writer
strike right now and we're not given the
value
of you know of of of being that
foundational creator
it's the starting point of everything
and we're overlooked
uh and marginalized and lumped together
well we can get this person in that way
you know and it becomes this mishmash
and then you end up with all this crap
content
yeah
it's very strange we're in this
transition phase with how
um
movies in television get made and how
they get distributed the the syndication
model the broadcast television model the
ancillary Revenue stream model all of
those are gone and we have these
streaming behemoths that
um do these buyouts where they pay all
the money up front for the talent
there's no ancillary revenue streams
coming later uh
and that's given them the opportunity to
shortchange talents yep uh mostly the
writers
on top of that there is an utter lack of
transparency around how many people are
seeing these properties how much money
they're making such that
um
you can't help but think
they're making more money than they want
you to know because if you knew there'd
be more than the writers just going on
strike right now totally is that a fair
assessment of the Landscapes
assessment and you know there's people
put in these positions it becomes just
another business metric right and again
the heart of of Storytelling what it
means and its impact
um has become so diluted and pushed away
it's become so separated from the
business aspect I understand it's a
business you know that money needs to be
made films are expensive to make
so but at the same time you've got
people in these positions that have no
idea about story about scripts you know
and they're giving you feedback or
they're green lighting Things based upon
what based upon you know how other
things have done well in the past or
what that package is but you know
nobody's read the can you make it more
like this oh God if I'm told oh can we
have another array can we have a female
John Wick please so
riddle when you're making the movie I
assume you're on set for well this is
the whole other story this is a travesty
so this happened during covert right so
we were not allowed to be unsafe
and after 16 years of getting this
project on board we're in La at short
and Prague
and we're having to watch it from afar
oh my God and that was the hardest thing
ever
it was brutal and it's like it's not
that like we wanted it wasn't about
input it wasn't about control it was
about the beauty of seeing these
collaborators come together why couldn't
they figure out a way to get you there
that's a whole other conversation
there's some political strings attached
to that one I got you oh that's a shame
I I just assumed you were there well
let's let's put it like this I think
ultimately there's a lot of people in
this industry that really don't give a
about other people
that what they've done to make something
happen
uh there's no empathy for a lot of
people out there and folks don't want to
help other people make their way up the
ladder unfortunately
yeah it's a zero-sum game perception but
yeah of course we know it's not Yeah the
more you help the more you get back yeah
of course it's a people it's a people
business right and people like to work
with the people that they like and
people remember when people were helpful
to them it's so insane that I don't get
it I don't get it but well I do get it
it's wrapped an eagle but
fear and greed and uh a lack mentality
there's only so many projects and only
so many people who can get credit
Etc
um the big question I have for you uh
who designed my Oscars dress no we're
gonna get to the Oscar stuff I'm working
my I've got lots of oscars questions but
here's the biggie uh you wrote the
screenplay obviously you you know Ian
and you you there's three of you
um but you option
the property and you renewed that option
for 16 years and made sure that you held
on to the rights to get that thing made
the role of producer the title of
producer uh can be defined in many ways
in my book that entitles you to a
producer credit yep so although you did
not receive the Oscar for best adapted
screenplay you won the bafta
um we're going to get into your reaction
to all of that uh
I'm curious why you're not accredited
producer on the film because I think
that you deserve yep an Oscar for best
picture so we are executive producers on
the project
so which is something we always well we
fought to have a full producing credit
and to be involved in that capacity they
only let how many
um for Oscar purposes four or something
there's no the the for Oscars I think
it's for
but there can be many producers and
approaches yeah yeah but only four can
be like Oscar contending we get to hold
the trophy guys yeah so and even that is
kind of contentious it depends on how
much input you've had in the project
itself during the production and of
course we weren't allowed on the
production right so therefore we
couldn't play a role I think you had a
little input yeah but you know it's one
of these things that you learn
unfortunately we had a good lawyer but
we were kind of caught between the rock
and a horror place in terms of
who we had involved in the project and
who we had to buy out or buy off to get
actually on the road to making it and so
we had to give up that full producing
credit in order to actually made yeah
that becomes a bargaining chip in
getting the movie yeah and we naively
thought that we could fight for it after
the fact but of course once you give up
that terrain you know right
have you seen the movie that you wrote
they're fighting over you know once you
give up a little bit you're not getting
it back you're not getting it back and
then especially if the person doesn't
want you to get it back they're going to
do everything to ensure that you can't
stake and claim Leslie do you know how
lucky you are like that we're gonna be
making this movie with you you should be
grateful oh my god do you know how many
times you said that to us yeah and of
course you know you're new to it right
you've been on this is your last chance
to win you don't have any more money to
renew an auction so you are incredibly
grateful so you're balancing between oh
my God I'm grateful that this thing got
made and then I'm frustrated that we're
not recognized just for what we did to
get it off the ground so
um it was you know that that that was a
Bittersweet pill to swallow and that
followed us around the award circuit and
it was
it was emotional it was hard we were
very much the odd ones out until we were
embraced
but
you know all you can hold on to is your
why
your why is what is this why am I doing
this I love to tell stories and if this
allows me to tell more then I'll suck it
up you know it's wank at the time but
you suck it up so I just kept coming
back to that
[Music]
um
and then also as well I'm never going to
do that to other people moving forward
I'm not gonna do that you know I'm going
to take care of the people that I work
with and make sure they're credited for
what they did
uh I'm gonna nurture people and Mentor
them and help them any way I can given
the circumstance and that was not our
experience
and you know I went out of my way to be
kind to
um be a collaborative to be supportive
to stand back
to support
and then it was kind of thrown in our
faces
um and not a lot of people know that and
it's difficult to dig into but it's been
a hell of a lot yeah and it doesn't it's
it would be
you know there's an argument that it is
uncouth to complain given you know the
trajectory of of your success to Grouse
about something like that well I think
it's as long as people know
our input and again
you know our input was big but at the
same time you know what they did in
production what Ed did as a director
what all these other heads of Department
it's a collaborative process it's
amazing we feel so bloody lucky like
yeah my question was was going to be
like when you were on set watching it
unfold did you have the sense that this
was something special about having been
I would have died of that I suppose you
were maybe you were zooming in or
whatever and getting glimpses of it but
probably not until you saw a first cut
of the movie did you get a sense of
whether this is even going to be good I
it's probably fair to say the finished
product exceeds what maybe you even
imagined it could be 100 but was there a
moment where you're like oh my God like
this is like even better than I expected
or I can't wait for people to see this
or were you thinking is any English
speaking person gonna watch a German
language movie like what was going on in
your mind around expectations do you
know when we saw some of the first shots
in some of the pictures and every frame
looked like a piece of art I was like
wow this is I mean at least we're gonna
get something for cinematography
but when we saw the first cut of the
film and I watched it you know you get a
link from Netflix you're allowed to
watch it within 24 hours and I watched
it with Simon and my mother and
father-in-law in England
uh Christmas whenever it was and um I
just sat here
the whole way through you know it was so
bizarre I was so surreal having gone on
this wild Journey then not being able to
be on set then watching your film and
it's yours but it's not yours
and it's beautiful and it's gorgeous it
was like a very bizarre experience and I
would say I'd take that emotion of of of
total joy and total devastation mesh it
together and that's how it's been for
the last you know I don't know eight
months like
you know yeah on so many different
levels
you're so accomplished and you've been
so successful uh so you know the idea of
another you know great height being
achieved probably feels more in your
grasp than it might to somebody else
um but I'm wondering whether you allowed
yourself to start thinking about things
like those external validations like
when does the Oscar you know possibility
enter your mind or was that not even
part of it it's just like I'm proud of
the movie I can't wait for people to see
it I mean I think it it always did you
always have a secret hope that it's
going to go that far but you can't
anticipate it so you can't that's what
you can't spend too much time putting
energy into that thing that you can't
control exactly and you really truly can
and that was the biggest thing that came
out of the Oscars I mean you can control
to a point if you've got a great company
and a lot of money behind you to create
an awards campaign that really gets a
word out but it is so political and it's
so complex that people have no yeah I
think people don't understand that it it
it is the campaign to Oscar is not
dissimilar from a presidential campaign
the amount of money and social
engagement that that goes into that is
insane and you want a studio who's like
we understand that and we're we have a
team that knows how to do that here's
all the money and Leslie here's your
calendar you're going to be going to
lunches and cocktail parties every
single day for the next 45 days totally
and you can imagine me I was like I'll
do everything I'm like I'm an endurance
athlete from two to five a.m and I will
be at that lunch in Beverly Hills but
the funny thing is is he didn't want to
involve us Ian and myself in the
campaign to begin with at all
so it was very much pitched why was that
a German authentic film
because we're not German we were adult
we were a scab that's awesome
interesting because you have the most
compelling human interest story of
anyone involved well they didn't know it
because nobody knew whoby bear because
we were pushed out
so again it depends on you know who's
creating the narrative
and where you sit within that and if you
are pushed to the side and you don't
fight for your place at the table then
Nobody's Gonna Know
so it took me a good friend of mine
Andrew kossoff who owns a big company
here I cycle with him
he paid for me because we couldn't
afford it he paid for me to have some PR
of my own
and that's when the first couple of
stories we managed to get in the big
Publications about who I was the what do
the Wall Street Journal piece come out
of that uh
it all escalated so it started with a
Hollywood reporter piece
that that Simon and I wrote
um and that that was the Costa Rica
story right and that just you know and
then all of a sudden it was like every
and then all of a sudden Netflix
realized oh oh this is your story oh and
you're a woman and oh as soon as it
became politically opportunistic for
them that was it they loved me so you
know yeah it's but you know I mean
all but that but they didn't know
right because the people in control of
the film didn't tell them
so and the people in control of the film
didn't know because they didn't ask
because he didn't care
so do you know what I mean it's like
we've got what we want so see you later
guys it's just a commercial reality of
how that stuff goes it can be it doesn't
need to be I've met plenty of people
that have amazing experiences and I've
had amazing experiences you know but at
the end of the day again like you know
you know Ford Oscars seven bath does
like come on like yeah so 14 bath
denominations seven wins including your
your screenplay
um you know and that was at a moment
where it was kind of shocking because it
was a sleeper
so I would suspect that your Camp was
you know more than delighted at that
result it certainly wasn't a given and
that created momentum going into the
Oscars big time
um nine nominations four wins and if you
watched the show there was a certain
kind of energy that felt like it was
building because you guys had a lot of
success early and it was like oh they're
gonna go like they're gonna because once
you you know get some of those other
Awards you think well they're just
knocking all the pins down from here oh
yeah and we truly saw that and I think
that that
the whole bathroom is so fascinating the
politics of it but I think we got such
support the baftas and in the UK because
it's a very European story sure it's a
European production and you know I'm
going to be contentious here and say
that
they focused on the craft of the film it
wasn't about the walk-ness of the
project not taking anything away from
the other projects but again it becomes
a political campaign when it comes to
Academy you know
is diversity represented is you know the
female voice represented all of these
issues then become this massive thing
whereas I'd say in the UK
all of that is almost kind of pushed
aside and it's like well which is the
best film you know in our ER
which has the best craft or why and and
so we had a sense we'd do well in the
bathtubs because in the campaigning up
to it like I am not joking I'd walk in a
room and people find out what you know
what what I was a part of they would get
down on their knees they'd be like oh my
God you know you're like wow this is
amazing
um so that was cool but the baftas
itself was the best night ever ever ever
ever ever it was so fun
um I managed to get a ticket from my mum
and she was like you know I mean like
she's in her 70s now my sister took her
out she got her fancy dress Netflix flew
her down fancy hotel the whole bit
Paparazzi outside I have my own dress
designer hair and makeup my old man
comes down with my stepmom
and it's like it's it's just on me and
then of course we went over them right I
mean it was like what and in that moment
The Surreal you know aspect of that
experience to reflect upon the 16 years
and the toil and the doubt and the
broken shoulder and the Lyme disease and
the you know
you name it that you endured to
persistently Shepherd this project to
fruition I mean it's unbelievable it's
it's awe-inspiring and Incredibly you
know it's just incredibly inspirational
it's on like on the stage that night was
pure joy I mean pure joy and afterwards
we went out and we parted until 4am
anybody that knows me knows like I'm
eight o'clock and I am in my bed you
know what I mean so 4am I was so hyper
and one of the best things was the next
night after baftas we took our parents
out from you like a fancy meal put the
bath in the middle
and to shade it with our families like
this massive journey and the success
like a really relished in it because I
feel like so much of my athletic career
I've been about the future and you know
what's next what's next you know oh my
God I can't live up to this I really
felt like during that time I was in the
moment
um and it was like James commentary yeah
it was it was it was so I'm not joking
when I say like massive stars are coming
up to you because I had yeah I know yeah
I want to hear about like I know you met
like Tom Cruise like throw some at me
what so you have this um you have the
the academy luncheon for nominees and
it's more relaxed people are chitty
chatting and of course Tom Cruise is
nominated and you're going around and
you're speaking to you know I've met
Steven Spielberg which was amazing
um a bunch of other people and Tom's at
this do and I see him and normally he's
got a ton of people around and there's a
little window and I go up to him and I
went hi Tom I'm Leslie Patterson with
all quite he said I know who you are I
know your story he said how many hours a
day do you train I'm like oh my God you
have a training you're gonna have a
training conversation with Tom I swear
to God like I'm desperate to meet him
again to like really dig into what he
does and how he recovers and that you
know but it was just that was very weird
so it's just and what you realize I mean
they're all for the most part I mean
they're all just people and the people
at the top generally are super nice
and they love what they do they're into
their craft they're that top one percent
right what is the the shared DNA
sensibility ethos between
Elite athletes and these Elite creatives
that you were able to bump elbows with
through that experience absolutely the
same it's not about outcome it's about
the process
so they love what they do they love
their craft every single minute of it
they're obsessed with being the best
that they can be
and every single moment to
and that's where their Joy comes not in
the end result the end result is like
the icing on the cake or but that's not
even you know so you all sort of you
Bond over the silliness of it of of the
end result in a way bit like
um yeah you really
you really relate to each other because
of the passion of why you're doing what
you're doing
there is something just completely inane
and absurd about pitting Creative
Expressions against each other in a
competition it makes no sense and yet
for some reason it it captures the
imagination of the world who wants to
see who's going to win these things but
the whole thing is just
I mean it doesn't make any sense there's
no there's no Rhyme or Reason or
objective way to say this movie's better
than that movie when they're just apples
and oranges and both beautiful
Expressions saying something interesting
and important and and resonant in their
own right totally but then and yet you
are an athlete and you are competitive
you don't win World Championships
without wanting that trophy yep so when
you're at the Oscars and it's your
category and they're listing out the
nominees and you're sitting there with
your speech in your hands yep what is
happening
it was brittle I have to say it was the
worst night of my life
everyone's like oh my God the Oscars
this and that but I was just what goes
on forever right like people aren't even
in their seats most of the time and
you're like is this ever gonna end it's
it is so exhausting because I started
getting ready at what I don't know 9 A.M
you've got dressed designers you're
getting hair and makeup you're this
you're that then you're driven there
then you're hanging around hours of
waiting and waiting and waiting and kind
of being uncomfortable kind of being
nervous then you're in the seat and then
you can't really absorb this is your
first Oscars you're wondering are you
ever gonna get there again there's a lot
of kind of like internal Devastation
about what's occurred anyway about your
lack of involvement
and then you're waiting there
and I've just spent the last three
months
talking about The Narrative of how
dreams come true and I can achieve
anything and am I amazing and the whole
of Scotland is behind you winning and
I'm sitting there I'm holding Simon's
hand I'm holding Ian's hand and I'm like
waiting for the name thinking oh this is
gonna happen I've willed everything into
existence so of course this is gonna
happen
and it doesn't
and I am not I am not joking when I say
I looked at Simon and went no
oh my God they didn't have a camera on
me I probably did they just chose not to
not to Cheers thank God I was
and it was so bizarre because in sport
you have time to get used to the
devastation because normally it's a
longer race you know whether you're
having a good one or not it's generally
not a Sprint finish
so you're kind of at peace with it I was
not at peace with this at all and
you know I I know Sarah Paulie who won
and she's amazing and she's gorgeous and
such a lovely person so you're
definitely happy for that
and then you're happy for the four
Oscars that you win you win best
International where you're not invited
on the stage which is another thing
and
again it's this weird dichotomy of like
you should be happy but you're
devastated you should be happy but
you're devastated and then pure
exhaustion of what you've just been
through and everyone telling you you
should be enjoying yourself right this
is the Oscars oh my God you know so
needless to say it was like the parties
afterwards I just wasn't interested in
and which is so crap to see but like I
find it really hard I just find it
really hard I appreciate the honesty you
know the political answer that you
always get is oh you know I was just
happy to be nominated or whatever the
reaction shots on the faces of the
people that don't win who are like it's
like those you're like no I'm pissed I
should have won I thought I should I
thought I deserved to win I didn't win
I'm mad how am I going to get back there
like yep that's the killer that wins
five World Championships coming out yep
you know this this like unicorn unlikely
animal who's found her way into this
creative world where that sensibility
isn't like doesn't quite jive with how
everybody else kind of functions as
Political Animals to
um you know make their way and I thought
I read that and I was like good for you
you were just like calling it like you
felt it and saw it yeah because it's do
you know it's funny because like I think
that maybe that's why I'll be successful
is because I'm I'm candidly honest but
in a nice way if it comes from a place
of this is my belief I'm gonna tell you
what I really think I'm in the nicest
way possible uh you know and I think
that's where true greatness comes
[Music]
um
yeah you know but but man but when I
reflect on that night and and all of the
other things we did have some good
moments in there you know I remember
after it happening around the bathroom
and here's the funny thing about the
Oscars right so
you know you're sat there and you have
these commercial breaks right and
they're like I don't know two and a half
minutes three and a half minutes
everyone's different and they don't tell
you when your category is coming up you
know roughly but not exactly
and they closed the doors if you
don't make it back from the loan time so
you can't get back in the auditorium
so you're sprinting in your heels and
dress to get the toilet so you can get
to do a piss come back and get in in
case you miss your category so I I
needed a bathroom after we lost and I
run down and you know I'm devastated I
come back up and I know a bunch of a
bunch more of our categories are coming
and I miss the doors you know I don't
make it back in time
uh but on the way Kate Kate blanchett's
there she gives me a big hug you know
and I'm like okay it's not that bad
really yeah okay the queen and I end up
hanging hanging outside with Phoebe
wallerbridge and she is as funny as you
can possibly imagine
so it's like you have all of these
little vignettes of moments that are so
fun and wild and amongst all of this
like just weird yeah
um you know I feel like I'm recovered
from it now but that next morning I I
cried all day Monday oh and it wasn't it
wasn't and again it wasn't so much even
about the fact that it was about the
fact that we lost but it was more about
I felt like this opportunity could
launch a career and it has already but
it could really launch it and that that
had been lost and compared to everyone
else involved in the production their
careers are already there and they're
already going ours are not this is our
first step and because we've been
marginalized so much in the lead up to I
felt like oh my God we've lost our
opportunity so that's what I felt
devastated
um but then you kind of kick yourself up
the backside and you say okay I'm just
gonna have to use it I've fought back
from worse like let's use what we've got
here it's still amazing
and you create your own opportunities
well I think people are are learning
more and more about the story I mean you
did win the bafta you got nominated for
an Oscar the doors are opening I do see
a bright future I mean of course you
would have liked it to have gone a
different way in a number of different
you know aspects of that whole journey
um but I don't know man I'm pretty
confident you're gonna figure it out you
I mean if you could be that persistent
focused diligent disciplined
hard-working to you know create what you
created in this project which let's face
it it's your first screenplay right
um I think that the skies are are
looking blue ahead oh they are yeah so I
know you got a you have a lot of
projects now is there one that can you
talk about what you're working on that's
coming up next yeah so we're shooting a
film in Scotland in October which is
really exciting it's a psychological
Thriller that we've written and produced
and we're producing and um we've got
Karen Gillen we think who is is coming
on board uh to Star on it so that's
that's Mega cool we have a big project
in Africa that's why we're in London
seeing the king of Ashanti and that's a
true story and we have an amazing
project set in The Travelers community
in Ireland
and it's like a father-daughter story
and a little bit like The Fighter
um and then we have a bunch of others
you know it's for us it's about jumping
into these crazy wild exciting worlds
and finding a commonality finding a
thematic Essence that digs into
something in our society that we want to
talk about that means something to us
beautiful and how are you gonna
um keep the training up or what is what
is the perspective on racing and all of
that like how does that fit in on a
relevance level and you know kind of uh
uh performance level for you racing
means something totally different to me
now it's it's a bike community
so I love to race now to go and meet my
friends and to have an experience not
for the outcome so I really actually
don't mind that much
um about the results which is both good
and bad
um so it's gonna be destination races
it's going to be fitting them and in
between films when I have the time when
I have the inclination training on set
having fun with that you know yeah
yeah I like that I mean I think that's
appropriate with everything else that
you have going on right now it is kind
of lunacy to for it to be different than
that you know honestly right oh totally
and I think it's just using it as
inspiration you know training and racing
is inspiration for my creative world now
rather than an end point right
um
I'm interested in you know when I
reflect back on the traits and the
behaviors that kind of LED you to this
place obviously there's talent and like
I keep saying the grit the perseverance
the discipline the hard work
um the mindset the positivity optimism
all of that I'm curious given that
you've said so many of these things are
deeply ingrained in just who you are and
the way you've always been how much of
this do you think is teachable because
you and Simon have written this book The
Brave athlete you talk about these three
different Minds for somebody who is
looking to level up their approach to
the things that they care about like
where can someone begin to cultivate
more of these
uh characteristics that could you know
lead them in a better Direction it's
incredibly teachable I'm I mean as you
well know you know folks like huberman
talking about it but you know the
neuroplastic to save the mind right you
can change the wiring in your brain and
I just view it like a muscle that needs
working out and you can change the
composition of that
um one of the most defining moments for
me in my sport was when Simon taught me
about the anterior cingulate cortex that
sits behind the eyes and it monitors
um emotional and physical pain and it
actually as it experiences adversity it
grows and gets denser I mean that that's
kind of a rudimentary sense of it
so for me it was like okay so if I do
harder things it's going to get bigger
so then I can cope with more harder
things oh that makes sense so then I
need harder things to do
so you know I think that's the essence
of understanding how the brain works and
that's what we get into in our book we
give a brain mental model so that people
can understand what's going on in our
heads that we're not crazy you know this
is actually you know these are the
reasons why we have thoughts and
feelings that we don't want and then
certainly in our book we get into
different categories like identity
confidence body image issues creating an
alter ego like all these different
things and we give tools right it's
almost like homework to work in it
because we work on our bodies but we
don't work on our brain right
so yeah and you know in the athletic
context I mean I love that it's
fantastic you know at the highest level
you have
um parity of of work ethic and for the
most part Talent like these people are
all incredibly talented there's only so
many hours in the day they're all
maximizing them at least in terms of
their physical training under
appreciated is the mental game and
perhaps that's because
it's less understood or at least the
principles or tools or strategies for
training the mind
um
are are are still something we're we're
like learning about right right
um and haven't been canonized to the
extent that like we know how to train
from a marathon like it's kind of like a
you know it's there's no you know big
secrets there but the Mind still is this
mystery box and to the extent that
through neuroscience and you know what
your husband does and people like
huberman
um are working on helping us to better
understand that and provide us with
tools where it's like oh if you do this
this happens in the same way you have a
physical muscular skeletal response to a
training stress that we can do this with
our minds that's really exciting and
seems to open up a you know a giant
Horizon in terms of performance
breakthroughs not just in athleticism
but in literally anything well it's
always been seen as aetherial thing the
separation of mind and body and now we
know through Neuroscience that there's a
physiological component to that and we
can have an influence on that so I think
it's just a paradigm shift isn't it and
that takes time
um and it can be uncomfortable it can be
frustrating but certainly what we've
tried to do is Define us a bit more and
to you know you know give tools give
strategies things are really like you
can taste them you can feel them you can
touch them and we came about that
because you know Simon's background
people like huberman but then for Simon
to peek behind the curtain of a crazy
pro athlete and be like out okay
I was tall listen to textbooks but now
I've seen what actually happens okay I
mean through like Imaging
well I just mean like living with a
professional athlete like what do they
go through what are the things that
impact them
um you know and how can we help with
that so often I would come back from
training and be like okay sorry I tried
this and I tried that from my mental
perspective and he'd be like oh well
that makes sense because the science
says this and that and maybe if you try
this and so we had this wonderful
intersection of this kind of creativity
of me figuring out how I work and
operate and then the science of Simon
coming together and having something
actually tangible yeah the experiential
with the academics yep yeah super
interesting
um all right we gotta wrap this up but I
I want to leave I want to kind of end
this with some practical tools or advice
for somebody who
is interested in learning more about how
performance works and how
it might benefit their life if they
um were to learn a little bit more about
the brain or are trying to find a way to
get more grit in their life or test
themselves in new and interesting ways
but are completely unfamiliar with how
they might Embark upon that
so read our book
here's your plug I'm serving it up see
so read our book and then you know do
something that totally scares you every
day I mean truly honestly
um and then get to know yourself you
know point the finger back who am I how
do I operate what works what doesn't
what I like what don't I like What's My
Heart of Darkness create your own film
World get to know your character
that would be my advice yeah create your
own Heroes Journey become the star of
your own movie
you've got it yeah
um beautiful that was really fun thank
you it was thank you so much for having
me on it's such an amazing story like I
I hopefully you know this will help get
get your narrative out there a little
bit more I find it to just be
captivating and the idea that you're
just at the beginning of all of this is
like really exciting well you know
hopefully we can make a film together
one of these days right that would be
cool in the meantime everybody if you
haven't seen All Quiet on the Western
Front I don't know what you're doing
make a point of uh checking that out
right away and if people want to connect
with you besides the book where's the
best place for them to find you uh you
can reach out to us at IMDb has my
information up there and also
braveheartcoach.com has more information
yeah I was gonna are you still coaching
you're not still coaching so a little
bit because you know what it's like I
love my athletes and my people you have
athletes under your belt right now so
yeah on the way to the Oscars I was
talking you know as an athlete about
wetsuits and watches and yeah oh my God
I can't believe you're still doing that
I know um yeah and you're you're social
media is Leslie does try it is right he
might need to change that a little I
mean you do do try it I do try yeah I
know that's kind of a point so it's uh
do you feel it feels reductive at this
phase of your life yeah all right all
right thanks
uh awesome that's so fun thank you
that's good oh my God I'm sweating
billets